democrats are trying to use the same
argument for the border crisis
that they have used for the coronavirus
pandemic that the trump administration
left them with a mess this week
president biden is trying to sell his
nearly two trillion dollar covet relief
package
white house correspondent peter ducey
has the latest tonight from the north
lawn good evening peter
good evening brett it's been almost two
weeks since president biden said
anything about what's going on at the
border the
administration is not hinting about any
presidential trips down to the southwest
instead dedicating this entire week as
of right now
to selling a stimulus package that
already passed
shots and arms and money in pockets
that's important
as the us government enters 100 million
doses of cova-19 vaccine distributed
and 100 million stimulus checks
deposited the president is taking a
victory lap i can report this isn't just
on the way it's here
sooner than many ever thought possible
the american rescue plan has already
passed
now the president will promote it stops
are scheduled in pennsylvania and
georgia as republicans argue the
president needs to pencil in a trip
to the southern border this is where he
should bring air force one
biden white house blames border problems
on president trump
but critics are pointing to the calendar
empirically it is entirely
you can't help but notice that the
administration changes and there's a
surge
that surge has feds looking to fill a
convention
center in dallas with up to 3 000
migrant teenagers for up to 90 days
according to the associated press
the biden border crisis though was
created by joe biden's promises of
amnesty and open borders
and free health care for illegals during
the campaign some democrats are
concerned
too congresswoman ilhan omar leads a
group of two dozen democratic lawmakers
asking ice to stop placing migrants in
local or state jails writing
conditions in municipal county and state
jails and prisons contracting with ice
to detain
immigrants mirror the systemic abuses in
privately operated immigration detention
facilities
including medical neglect long-term use
of solitary confinement
sexual assault and lack of access to
legal counsel
to date the white house has avoided
calling the situation at the border a
crisis we recognize this is a big
problem we recognize this is a problem
it's a complicated problem
but now that the dhs is directing fema
resources to the border
what does the white house call what's
happening does fema's
arrival at the border mean that the
administration feels what is happening
down at the border is a disaster i know
that we always get into the fun of
labels around here but i would say our
focus is on
solutions specifically their mission is
helping people before
during and after disasters i will say
that
fema is there to help
ensure that the people who are at the
border who are coming across the border
have access to can to hhs and orr
shelters
that we can swiftly place them with
vetted families
i also had a chance to ask jensaki
whether or not the white house is moving
on from their message to migrants that
now
is not the time to come since fema is
saying they will shelter
unaccompanied kids for months and she
said
they're trying to have both those
messages out there
right peter ducey live on the north lawn
peter thanks